la gráfica de abajo contiene un
triángulo a bp dibuja la imagen del
triángulo a bp bajo una potencia cuyo
centro es p y cuya razón de potencia es
un tercio cuáles son las medidas del
lado ave y de su imagen ok entonces
recuerden que para una potencia con
centro en p y razón de potencia un
tercio lo que pasa es que todos los
puntos se van a alejar o acercar ap con
un factor de un tercio por ejemplo p
está una instancia cero del pp por lo
tanto bajo la potencia se queda en donde
está el punto a por el contrario está a
nueve unidades por debajo de p tienen la
misma coordenada x y la coordenada y
quisieran nueve unidades por lo tanto si
lo multiplicó por la razón de motes ya
que es un tercio obtengo nueve por un
tercio que es tres por lo tanto sólo voy
a estar tres unidades por debajo de p
23 hay ahora que hay debe de estar a
nueve unidades por debajo de p en la
coordenada i y está a menos ocho menos
dos entonces estas seis unidades en la
dirección x por lo tanto en la
coordenada y pasa a estar a nueve a
estar a tres y en la coordenada x pasa a
estar de seis va a pasar a seis por un
tercio que es 2 por lo tanto 12 en la
dirección x y 123 en la dirección y esa
sería la imagen del triángulo a bp ahora
me preguntan cuánto mide ave pues mide
menos 2 menos -8 que sería 6
y cuáles son las medidas de la imagen de
ave pues la imagen ya ve es este
segmento de aquí y es la diferencia
entre su coordenada x que es de -2 menos
menos 4 que sería 2 por lo tanto este
lado se contrajo con una razón de un
tercio se hizo más pequeño a un tercio
del tamaño y de hecho si checan los
demás lados también se redujeron en un
factor de un tercio por ejemplo el lado
tv en la upv media 9 al cuadrado más 6
al cuadrado 9 al cuadrado es 81 6 al
cuadrado es 36 por lo tanto eso suma 125
en raíz cuadrada eso me da 15 el lado
tve media 15 unidades y ahora cuánto
mide la imagen mide 3 al cuadrado más 4
al cuadrado que es 9 16 que es 25 y en
raíz me da 55 es un tercio de 15 por lo
tanto ese lado se contrajo también con
una razón de un tercio